[Music]
welcome to fat man beyond I'm Kevin
Smith I am mark Renard how's everybody
doing man we are here at the scum and
villainy Cantina in Hollywood California
right here in Hollywood Boulevard put
your hands together so the folks
listening and watching at home know that
you were real so much real gotta
remember LA real is everywhere else fake
so that's as good as it gets
how are you good sir I am [ __ ] great
bucket whoa that's very positive
I know I'm always get blown before the
show was you would know that's true
I'm just overcompensating for like
unemployment oh you don't have a job I
don't have a job you both [ __ ] you just
can't turn to the script for [ __ ] I
did which means I'm out of a job
mark turned in his first draft of his
Masters of the Universe script for
episode three so now we have three
scripts insofar as the first episode
which I rodeo wrote the second episode
mark just turned in the first draft of
the third episode Tim goes next and then
Eric brings us to five and stuff so that
that gives powerhouse a bunch of [ __ ] to
start working with and stuff so it's
it's exciting well how did you like
we're gonna I can't we gotta be real
[ __ ] careful about details and [ __ ]
cuz we already got told like shut the
[ __ ] up you're saying too many things
yes I like this ain't your show when I
was like I read in the [ __ ] Hollywood
Reporter it was you know like no no no
so we got to be very careful with the
details of [ __ ] but how did you like I
want to talk about the length and can't
even that no it's uh it was it was
injured I've never written animation
before mmm so it was an interesting sort
of challenge to a convey law that should
realizing that artists are gonna be
drawing it's actually a little bit like
writing comics because you're writing in
comics you're writing a letter to the
artist who's gonna draw your comic and
say here's kind of what I feel like the
mood should be and the color should be
in the like do what you're gonna do
because you can draw this [ __ ] way
better than I can
but in my head it feels like this and so
I think a lot of this was also that same
thing like knowing full well that you
were the first person who's gonna read
it
there's gonna be Mattel and Netflix
you're gonna have notes but the people
to execute it want to know kind of what
you were thinking yeah I think that's a
lot of what the at least this draft was
now it should be like pink skies and red
seas or vice versa
just like here's kind of the color
scheme and make it feel a tunnel using
this comic book that I wrote a long time
ago that's here on the bar meant for me
to sign not as some prop where I'm like
well mark I just happened to have one of
my own comic books it was left here for
me to sign but my point ban is a 22 page
comic book if I remember correctly I
haven't opened it I'll carnac that you
22 page comic book and I'll tell you
right now the script for it was not 22
pages if you looked at the script for a
movie that I'm directing let's say Jay
and Silent Bob reboot come in theaters
next month you would not see a lot of
description you'd see a [ __ ] ton of
dialogue but you would see the bare
minimum of descriptive passages to set
the scene like you know it it's just not
necessary because it's I'm gonna direct
it why am I gonna waste script space
going like you know Jay enters the room
Jay 45 long hair privileged middle-aged
white man you know [ __ ] like that and
I'm not saying I'm he's [ __ ] on that
I like when screenwriters do that in
their [ __ ] but in my [ __ ] I ain't got
time I'd rather use that space for a few
more dick jokes so so in a script for a
movie it's very [ __ ] tight no
description the script for this 22 page
comic book I guarantee you if I remember
correctly was 60 pages because in order
to get to 22 pages which you know has
let's say minimum six panels per page on
each page in order to get there the good
folks the good couple Dotson Terry was
the artist and Rachel was the the anchor
and stuff
the Dodson's had to draw [ __ ] tennis
[ __ ] but since they didn't write it
since they're not made they don't
[ __ ] know
what's supposed to happen so I couldn't
just right you know panel one the
spider-man black cat and then a bunch of
dialogue you have to say you know panel
one they're in a room the room is this
size there's a credenza over there you
have to literally describe everything
you want to see because you can't then
like when they show you some art you're
like what the [ __ ] where's the credenza
and they're like credenza like who even
uses that anymore you know so it's same
thing with animation
you really have to over describe [ __ ]
you know in just knowing that it's gonna
leave your hands and go into the hands
of people that you're not gonna be
standing next to to to be like oh when I
wrote that six months ago I meant this
you know they're gonna do with it what
they will and stuff so you got to be
very detail-oriented and which is a real
[ __ ] because again I can't talk about
specifics but the for me I'd rather put
as little description and as possible so
I could keep as much dialogue as
possible and you know this is a show
that's gonna have a lot of [ __ ] fighty
fighty in it as well so you got to leave
space for that but at the same time it
is a show about relationships and so
there's a [ __ ] ton of you know dialogue
and whatnot you got to find out balance
and for the length that [ __ ] I'm gonna
get in trouble
the is just tough like cuz you're you
want to describe everything but at the
same time you're like [ __ ] that took up
a quarter of a page and that means I got
to lose some dialogue in the story but I
don't want to lose dialogue because the
page count is very [ __ ] tight can't
go over it can't be like sloppy and come
cecum saw has to be very tight because
the animators are like if we're gonna
hit the [ __ ] schedules there this is
how it works like welcome to our world
and [ __ ] like view writers are wonderful
thank you for your words but the real
work begins now you know and then they
go to work I know and I I I really like
writing action scenes like I have the
most fun doing the reality yeah that's
the [ __ ] I can't stand the most man
that's thought I mean I talked about it
when we did the panel like the
powerhouse folks like Brad & Co guys who
are animating it they did castlevania
they were like look don't go crazy
describing your fights man
you know unless there's action very
specific to your plot like he punches
him in the eye and it's the eye that he
put in there before and it pops and
[ __ ] you know the world explodes he
goes unless and and that's not in the
script it'll be better than that if
you're if you don't need action specific
beats they said just write fighty fighty
and we'll take care of the rest so
they're like just have them speak and do
all the dialogue you need to and then
tell us who it is which you know people
are pairing off who's in the scene but
then right fighty fighty and that's what
we're here to do we're here to [ __ ]
bring it to vibrant life and [ __ ] and
that made me feel good because I'm like
[ __ ] hate writing action I'm lazy by
Nature
you just made an easy job even easier
thank you so much and it broke my
[ __ ] heart really I love that [ __ ] I
love like the Rube Goldberg nature of
like just building a fight scene that
makes sense because fight scenes when
they're shitty
they're just people punching each other
in the face and that's still kind of fun
but when they're great it's part of the
narrative right like you think about a
Jackie Chan fight scene like there's
there's full story Freight that's being
delivered to the audience in those fight
scenes I mean [ __ ] Rocky is nothing
but like if you if you tell me that I'm
gonna do the last fight and Creed and I
just get to write fighty fighty and I
don't get two punches he falls down he's
lying on the ground as mad as back in
spasm there's no what to do and then pop
he gets one flash of Apollo Creed and
then he jumps to the [ __ ] his feet as
I pulled by a [ __ ] anchor and then
you get the [ __ ] music then the music
kicks in the bill conti scene and then
you're like if I just gotta write are
you [ __ ] pitching it to me but like
that's the [ __ ] that makes me have so
much fun and I just fighty fighty have
fun see that's right
that's what makes the greats great like
Ryan Coogler probably him and his friend
wrote that script and they were [ __ ]
lifelong fans they're always like what
if Apollo [ __ ] won and so that's what
Creed isn't so they probably did break
it down like [ __ ] poetically beat for
beat so that you could almost see it as
you're reading the script whereas if I
was doing Creed it litter litter
would have been 12 pages long because it
would have been a lot of like oh yeah
you better believe fighty fighty just
give it to saudis one through nine
mighty fighting
what have I been doing I watched a thing
right before I came here what was the
thing that you watched the x-men movie
Dark Phoenix you did that on purpose and
everything told you like a car accident
I was like oh [ __ ] Dark Phoenix no his
total choice it was available on [ __ ]
Apple and iTunes and I had two hours for
the show and I was like this is relevant
to my interest and so I clicked on it
and watched it and it's under two hours
so I was able to get it all in number
one like I found it totally watchable I
was at home I didn't pause to [ __ ] off
or anything like that and I was eating
hummus what was going on so and I love
me some [ __ ] hummus so that probably
made it better if I could have seen it
in a movie theater eating hummus I too
would have been apart from the crowd
like I don't know what you [ __ ] are
talking about a lot more it was I
thought it was totally watchable and and
you know for the first like half I was
like [ __ ] alright down there doing it
what is everyone talking about I didn't
think was that bad
and then the you know the third act
kicks in and you're like I see it wasn't
like the third act was honestly I liked
it a lot more than [ __ ] the previous
x-men movie Phillips yeah ain't that
beige of apocalypse Jesus that woman
that was that one was tough man but this
one I didn't wasn't nearly stuffed and I
watched the other one at home too so it
should have gone down smoother and
whatnot but this one did totally [ __ ]
like I've sat there watching fairly
enjoying felt a bit sentimental because
I'm like oh she had man I've been
watching x-men movies for a while and
then [ __ ] did the mental math where
I'm like they're in a single [ __ ] in
this movie was in the first x-men movie
is there
and that [ __ ] weird like they just
suddenly and slowly rebuilt the entire
[ __ ] vehicle like from the bumper to
bumper with all new parts and we still
accepted it as the x-men there's not a
single person who was in the first x-men
movie not [ __ ] nuts
I mean it's nuts except like we unseen
Sean Connery in public since forever
like they've been they've been
rebuilding bonds as you go yeah that
doesn't seem as nutty to me but he told
us with bond right then now it's like
here's the new bond cuz it's a guy one
guy and when they switch him out you're
like I kind of noticed something
happened there but with the x-men man
there's so [ __ ] many of them they
stood it like over time they were like
just trade those two for young people
swap in another two now two and so I get
as I'm sitting there watching the movie
trying to get sentimental
I couldn't get sentimental cuz I'm like
who are these [ __ ] people like these
[ __ ] people but I've been with them
for the last few movies and [ __ ] was
kind of a slow shift
I think everyone involved this talented
so I'm not like taking anything wet but
I think Jessica Chastain was not served
at all no and if if I don't know there's
a choice or somebody directed her to be
like just play it like you don't want to
be in this movie the whole [ __ ] time
she's just like come with me Jean like
just look sad to be there and [ __ ] good
great actors but it's really they didn't
serve her very well I know there's a
bunch of reshoot and stuff like that
what did I tried to think like what did
what did I really [ __ ] like think was
like holy [ __ ] that's a vast improvement
and you know cuz it they're making
enough of them they should get a little
better each time presumably right you'd
hope yeah it says the guy who just
[ __ ] made Jay and Silent Bob reboot
he hopes as well the BAM the
Nightcrawler in and out was really
[ __ ] beautifully done like they got
that [ __ ] down no science just in time
for the whole [ __ ] franchise to end
and [ __ ] but it looks really [ __ ]
graphically cool but is it is it done
better or to better effect than it was
an x-men 2 because the opening of x-men
2 is fantastic yeah like it's it's it is
almost also yeah often less the quality
the effect and more the use of the
effect you're using hmm and so which is
why you look at Jurassic Park and like
oh no they had a hundred CG shots in
that movie and it's looking puppets and
armatures and and just like trickery in
the camera and it looks as good if not
better than most movies do today because
they just they pick those shots
here's huge we're gonna spend this money
here's we're gonna innovate here's where
how we're gonna give you a [ __ ] field
of Gallimimus azure whatever the [ __ ]
those were and like the the opening ten
minutes of x-men 2 is probably the best
10 minutes of an excellent movie you're
ever going to get and it's 15 years old
at this point and it is it's smart it's
hard to innovate on smarts when all
you're doing is trying to vamp [ __ ] and
imagine think about that with like how
what an electrifying sequence that was
particularly if you were a comic book
fan cuz you're like holy [ __ ] my whole
life I've been reading these books
I watched the [ __ ] cartoons and [ __ ]
and they literally made it happen
like [ __ ] Nightcrawler vamped and
then BAM out and [ __ ] oh so dope in the
attack sequence but I loved his
Nightcrawler the new kid is fine he's
good but Alan [ __ ] was adorable when
he was just like you know I was what was
it he was like I was the number one act
in the Munich circus it was like so so
[ __ ] happy to be called somebody
leaps in man yeah so it was weird to
watch the x-men franchise just kind of
come to an end like you know when they
started making that movie there was no
whiff of the Disney deal I don't know so
they didn't think they were making the
last x-men movie no this is gonna crust
us into a whole new generation of x-men
yeah didn't know that was kind of it man
yeah I watched a movie hold on what was
the last thing I wanted to point out oh
I saw like they had done Dark Phoenix in
x-men 3 the one Brett Ratner did and
everyone [ __ ] on and whatnot but to be
honest I like their act 3 better than
this act 3 ironically both were written
by Simon Kinberg yes but this one I had
real no no emotional connection to is
just a giant CG like [ __ ] mouth you
mean with like what's her name Sansa
Stark they paid her a lot of money the
the Sansa Stark Jonas I'm sorry they
paid her a lot of money to stand in
front of a green screen for a long time
and do [ __ ] like this and she was like
are you sure that's it they're like we
got the rest man get the [ __ ] out of
here man
we gotta go go will crack your skin
light was gonna be awesome
so it was that was fine kind of standard
but the third act in you know I'm not
[ __ ] just trying to reconvince
anybody I'm Brett Ratner but the third
act of x-men 3 is [ __ ] Wolverine
trying to get to gene who's so [ __ ]
powerfully destructive it's she's
destroying everything around her and his
flesh is getting [ __ ] ripped off of
his face as [ __ ] Hugh Jackman like
tries to robot in honor through the
[ __ ] force field and he's getting
sprayed down to [ __ ] bone and then
regenerate it like it is synthesis and
if Ziff that's not [ __ ] metal enough
he finally reaches her and he's like
faked and they like what the [ __ ] like
it was better than the one they did in
the comics I'll be honest with you the
death of Jean Grey in the comics was not
nearly as [ __ ] cool was that so this
one I felt was just kind of like no but
that one I was like holy [ __ ] he was all
crying and [ __ ] if your hero has to kill
the woman he loves to save the world
that is way better than took us a while
across this street here in Manhattan and
that's the lesson you got out of the
lesson I got is don't ever make an x-men
movie without Hugh [ __ ] Jackman man
cuz I was sitting there watching this
movie gone something's [ __ ] missing
man something's wrong
they replaced everybody they left the
engine out on [ __ ] lawn man it's just
a car without the [ __ ] heart and [ __ ]
so it was it's worth the watch if you
haven't seen that ferry but just know
that like this is what I would suggest
because again written by simon kingberg
and he directed this one though so watch
the first two acts of Dark Phoenix and
then switch over to x-men threes third
acts and I think you'll be very happy I
think you'll be like nice but awesome X
just gonna machete cut these two things
together I think but I was waiting you
know everyone I think you shed on the
two and I think everybody was like
lowered my expectations but because they
were in the toilet I guess I was like
hey this ain't [ __ ] bad we all did it
for you man thank you I really
appreciate so one of us could enjoy it
I'll say this much man if I was doing
like one of those videos and [ __ ] like
honest trailers or [ __ ] cinemasins
holy [ __ ] if if everyone in that movie
or even just Sansa Stark Jonas
got paid by the Jean people be [ __ ]
rich man they said that name so [ __ ]
much - Jean Jean Jean Jean Jean Jean
Jake Jean the whole [ __ ] movie by the
end when the credits rolled man I turned
to my wife I was like was that
character's name the dancing machine
they did and then also it reminded me
that she doesn't really have a secret
identity in the comics it was Marvel
Girl right but they never did that in
the x-men movies no just Jean so weird
everyone's got a code name the [ __ ]
Nightcrawler [ __ ] Cyclops Jean Grey
weird in any event totally why what did
you watch that you uh I I went to go see
the 20th anniversary re-release of the
matrix and I I was gobsmacked I mean
it's gorgeous like the the restoration
is amazing the sound work the sound sort
of refurbishment first wait what year
twenty five twenty twenty ahthe ninety
nine same ears table yeah there's a big
year same year six cents yo and
something else just hit to Mary
Shawshank Shawshank American Beauty
there was a big [ __ ] summer Wow
no Shawshank is not a twenty five years
so they were nineteen ninety-four yeah
right but I I found myself wondering
what it felt like and I couldn't quite
put a finger on it but what it felt like
to watch the matrix for the first time
because that movie is [ __ ] up like
like a really good [ __ ] up like a
really like I'm not sure what I'm
watching at any given moment [ __ ] up
and then it starts like peeling back
layers and the [ __ ] beneath it is just
as [ __ ] up and then there's more
layers like and I remember the the all
of the marketing language was basically
nobody can tell you what the matrix is
you just have to see it for yourself and
somehow that got us to go see the
[ __ ] matrix and it's it is so heady
in a way that I haven't honestly seen
since maybe inception is playing with a
similar you don't know what's happening
you just know that it looks kind of cool
and they keep talking about things that
feel cool even if you don't know why and
and I was just I was blown away by the
fact that Warner Brothers made that
movie mmm it's a giant like it's a giant
[ __ ] studio movie they handed it to
two filmmakers who had previously they
wrote they wrote the matrix solar to
Warner Brothers wanted to direct and
they said no because you've never made
anything the only thing that it was
bound Warner Brothers made them go made
them make bound first like bound was
their tryout for the matrix right they
make us this like six million dollar
like you know lesbian noir go to town
you would never see two more different
movies either like well you don't watch
[ __ ] bound and go like I could see
the matrix coming
although like if you watch the matrix
and then you go sea-bound you're like oh
no yeah there's some of this in the 8c
some DNA there's there some DNA but like
to hand those two cats that movie and
like oh yeah we're gonna invent special
effects they don't exist and it's also
gonna be about like the nature of
reality and some al-qura and like we're
gonna name the ship the Nebuchadnezzar
which is a deep [ __ ] Bible cut that
nobody's gonna quite catch but sure
we're gonna do all that we want to get
Will Smith to star in it is that cool
yeah but will won't work for us after
wild well West so who else you want I
don't know about Keanu sure I guess we
wanted this to be a super black movie so
I guess we got to take one white guy
which is fundamental as if you see like
that other Matrix movies they are super
[ __ ] black like it's as if it's a lot
like fashion the theories that way where
they were like saddled with the one
white guy they started with and then
just eventually just replaced everybody
else until they're like various shades
of brown but by the time you get to like
crazy dance rave and Zion like oh this
is just Soul Train a white dude and his
white girl like up in the alcove kind of
[ __ ] maybe but then is Morpheus
everybody dance and then it's just like
speech and it's rain everywhere and
[ __ ] the see-through dresses
I mean [ __ ] like what was it like to
see the matrix of the first time I
remember seeing matrix 2 for the first
time and that [ __ ] began and I was like
did is this somebody else's movie what
happened to the good one and the dance
sequence was just [ __ ] long and weird
and I'm like wow this is what they were
fighting for I wish they hadn't gone
back to Zion an analyst liked it better
in the [ __ ] matrix yeah but it's uh
it's it's an incredibly smart movie that
that rewrites its rules as it goes and
doesn't actually wait for you to catch
up to what those rules are gonna be yeah
and and the fact that we all kind of got
on board and we now look at it as if
it's oh it just exists because it always
existed it's a [ __ ] matrix why
wouldn't you it's a it's a remarkable
piece of work
that I don't think I'd ever quite given
it credit for
well because it's just so [ __ ] deep
you know in a in a milieu also deep word
that never rewards death you know what's
gonna happen once your [ __ ]
shoot each other what are they doing
wearing black leather that seems cool
right yeah I just saw that equilibrium
movie and the [ __ ] Christian Bale and
Taye Diggs was in it's not as deep let's
just do whoa this is super [ __ ] deep
yeah it is I remember seeing the trailer
for the matrix and being like this looks
like that Dark City movie mm remember
cuz that had happened right before and
stuff I was like these movies look
awfully [ __ ] similar and [ __ ] so I
went in with real low expectations early
in my relationship with my wife let me
see
she was I came out and may yes I think
if I remember correctly so she'd know
lately so that's point we got a like a
two month old kid and we brought Harley
to see the matrix in a bassinet and I
remember somebody complimented us on the
way outcome there was a lot of gunfire
that's a good baby
[Laughter]
thank you she's an American yeah man it
was it March fine whatever thanks Nate
also means my story like didn't happen
because the kid was born in [ __ ] June
what the [ __ ] man
his Fight Club that I took her to see
she just fact checked us both straight
now really [ __ ] thanks Nate
but yeah I think it's it's playing until
this Friday when it gets blown up by
something else so if you can go see it
because it's it's worth seeing on the
big screen again just for how [ __ ] up
and wonderful it is hmm
I got one last opening thing and then
you got a bunch of news I do yes there
was things happening I didn't know if I
was allowed to talk about this but I've
now seen it all over [ __ ] the news
cycle so I guess it's okay I went to a
wedding this weekend a wedding yes and
it's very on-brand for this show here
and particularly very on-brand for me
I I saw two superheroes get married
Melissa Benoist and Chris Wood got
married Melissa plays Supergirl Chris
played Mon L on Supergirl couple seasons
back they've been together for like
since then for about two three years or
whatever and they just got married in
what is honestly the best wedding I've
ever been to in my life
it changed the game for me like where I
was just like your next wedding yes I
turn to my wife eyes are gonna do it
better next time just wait it was so
beautiful like I don't think I'll have I
don't think I can ever go to a wedding
again and enjoy it nearly as much unless
two actors are getting married because
it was so emotive man everyone just wore
our hearts on their [ __ ] sleeve you
know you go to weddings people are very
like kind of like circumspect and like
you read their vows if they read them at
all or just repeat what this guy says
and [ __ ] like that
and but it's very you know most people
aren't used to being in front of people
and [ __ ] and it's biggest day of your
life but still you're nervous and
there's a
[ __ ] Anthony eight and blah blah blah
you these two men like they're artists
so the [ __ ] world melts away and it's
just them and the two of them wrote
their own vows and they were [ __ ]
breathtakingly breathtakingly beautiful
I'm not just saying that as a guy who
like their friend and I like them and
[ __ ] like you know I know Chris is a
really [ __ ] good writer he just sold
the script to plan B to [ __ ] that
company and [ __ ] but he just clever and
smart in real life and [ __ ] like a
beautiful I hate him and I always told
him I was like [ __ ] did it fair like
you're so good-looking and you're
[ __ ] talented god dammit she is about
the sweetest human being on the planet
just the absolute light of the world and
so two kids came together on that show
and that they found each other in the
weird wild world not impossible because
you don't say this about many people
just it's the old chestnut like they're
made for each other but that's really
not true it feels like these two were
[ __ ] literally made for each other
man and they rock these [ __ ] vows
that me as a writer I was like [ __ ]
that's good and like and I knew he was
gonna be [ __ ] real good because I've
read his writing I've read a couple of
his scripts you know Melissa I don't
think I've never read anything that
Melissa wrote and stuff so I was like
you know she went first and I was like
this poor son of a [ __ ] man because
like I knew woods would be stunning
but Melissa wrote some of those
beautiful [ __ ] I've heard my life I
started crying while she was doing her
vows and she's crying and he's crying
[ __ ] I look around everybody's
[ __ ] crying man the vows are good
long like four minutes and you know
she's just reading them this thing that
she wrote and she opens with like you
know I don't I'm not good with words and
then proceeds to write one most eloquent
beautiful things ever heard in my life
she wraps it up and it ends and [ __ ]
the whole we're out so the wedding was
outside everyone is silent it's just you
know quiet and [ __ ] because we all just
experienced something [ __ ] real
and then some [ __ ] [ __ ] in the
audience goes oh come on and starts
[ __ ] clapping I was that ass cuz I
couldn't [ __ ] believe what we just
heard I was like oh come on everybody if
I can applaud his start laughing and
[ __ ] and I was like top that [ __ ] would
ya thank God we weren't in a church and
then he went and he was just as [ __ ]
eloquent and beautiful man like it was
it was so moving it was the kind of
thing that like made you fall in love a
little bit more with your wife and I
love my wife very much I don't need any
help there but like [ __ ] seeing that
I was like not a test chest but [ __ ]
like I was too I mean that was like
grabbing her titty like right it's hot
they love each other so much no you're
not a church it's fine thank God we're
outside our keep grabbing her [ __ ]
arm and my wife who I dearly love don't
get me wrong but you know who's been
with me but we've been to go 21 years
we've married 20 years
mother of my child and stuff everything
the reason for my being that being said
is one of the coldest [ __ ] human
beings I've ever met in my life she
ain't like me like I cried during
episodes of the flash and she looks at
me and goes oh and walks out and [ __ ]
she's very strong individual and [ __ ]
you don't understand how like I go to
peace is so easy I'm like a middle-aged
owner [ __ ] you everything's so beautiful
and she's she was [ __ ] bawling like
not just like rolling a tear my wife was
crying so hard she grabbed my tie and
[ __ ] wiped her eyes and [ __ ] like
that
[ __ ] Nate goes that's all you got of
the stories like you wore a tie I did
not only did I wear a tie we're [ __ ]
pain I went out and bought clothes for
the [ __ ] Dan by myself I wasn't even
brought by somebody who was like this is
what you have to do I was like I should
get like you know I knew I was gonna
wear a suit jacket and I knew in terms
of pants I couldn't go much further than
jeans but I knew I could wear you know
dressy jeans and [ __ ] like that and
that's pants more or less and so so I
knew I had that covered but all I got
are [ __ ] t-shirts and [ __ ] so I was
like oh [ __ ] I need a you know shirt
shirt shirt the non TV version of your
language are you saying somebody say
buttons boom a dress I had to get a boo
boo boo boom a dress shirt and some ties
because I didn't have any of that [ __ ]
to so I went to Macy's and [ __ ] shop
like a big boy and bought a white
button-down shirt and a [ __ ] black
button-down shirt in case I wanted to
wear it under the purple and [ __ ] I was
like you know suddenly I'm like who are
you Kevin Smith like it's [ __ ] we're
the hockey jerseys but I went home with
my [ __ ] you know and I thought my wife
would be like oh I'm so proud of you but
instead I became this [ __ ] individual
just focus of mockery and [ __ ] cuz I
came in with a bag she was like what's
that and I was like oh I got clothes for
the wedding and she was like let me see
you know like I was nine you know and
she's like she [ __ ] makes a big show
she's like glue what do we have here
pastel tie who are you Kevin Smith yeah
nice spy I bought two other ties and
she's like who one is black with white
dots and others black she's like so many
options and then she pulled out the two
shirts and she's like white or black
you're the Oreo of fashion and she was
like making fun of me and I was like you
know how can i if I'm damned if I do
damned if I don't just be glad I'm not
wearing a [ __ ] Jay and Silent Bob
shirt and [ __ ] like that so we went and
like I put I look good I still wore a
baseball cap and [ __ ] but like I look
cleaned up as wearing nice Hugo Boss
jacket and even my wife was like you
look [ __ ] good
but Melissa god bless her in the middle
of her [ __ ] nuptials in her big day
who was just radiant and [ __ ]
beautiful and everything and stuff like
at one point like after the ceremony
won't you know the gern that was the
thing afterwards like a reception
reception if I could sitting around
chitchat and doing taking pictures and
one night like she came over gave me a
hug and and she gave Jenna hug and stuff
and then she moved on and Jennifer was
laughing I was like what are you
laughing about she's like Melissa leaned
in it was like Kevin wore pants all the
CW the family was there and shared like
that all the people from Supergirl David
Harewood who plays Martian Manhunter
officiated the ceremony
there and so it was very very cool yes
I'm now not much Malad to say but I'm
basically I'm just saying [ __ ] that I
saw in a tweet so I'm like who I should
be safe at this point but it's really
cool I have no proof the event happened
because very wisely when we got there
instantly they were like surrender your
phones please
so all our phones went into a safe
keeping place and you know we all
[ __ ] for the first few minutes
stumbled around like [ __ ] fish on the
land going what the [ __ ]
but then we remembered like how to
breathe and [ __ ] like that and and it
was really quite nice like I got to say
I enjoyed the wedding a hundred percent
more than I would have because if I had
a phone I would have been like I don't
capture this and you're trying to look
for a shot and suddenly it's about you
and what you're capturing and you're not
even in the moment anymore you know so
even if you do this while you're
watching is still life through the black
mirror so to speak and stuff on Netflix
so I was just like stunned by like oh my
god like never mind the whole like you
know check and you know [ __ ] texts
and social media and [ __ ] like that like
we just we were all there we were all
present and also because there were no
phones at [ __ ] they could be themselves
like work blue they they they were
really smart to do it man like we all
got to kind of be there and focused and
[ __ ] like that nobody was like then
afterwards here in the reception we all
sat at one long table and nobody was
checking their phones because nobody had
their [ __ ] phones like it was really
really really cool man but beautiful
those I love those two kids dearly man
I'm not really like into people and [ __ ]
like that
I like I believe in people I'm positive
but but I don't like at one point Chris
was introducing me to somebody his
sister and last night and whenever it
was a Sunday night and he goes this is
Kevin he goes he's our biggest fan and I
was a guy and like I love that these two
kids like God together I saw it early on
like in the first episode of super girls
direct and I was like these cats got
real like chemistry and [ __ ]
so they got married and in fuggin we all
wish them congratulations give it up for
Melissa Chris they got married
alright that there is our intro stuff
now we get to the nitty gritty of this
year show mr. mark barnard used to be a
news hound for a living ship before he
used to before he took over writing
about people on Eternia he used to do
that kind of thing man on a typewriter
he wrote news when he was a kid then he
grew up in he edited news is some of the
most trusted news agencies in the world
The Hollywood Reporter the LA Times
Playboy and then one day he stopped
doing the news but it's still in his
blood so he's the guy that we sent
looking for the news and I bet you got a
[ __ ] ton of news this week bet you a lot
of it has to do with the [ __ ] Joker
we're about to find out because mr. mark
barnard and collected the news give it
up for Marquis got news I really now I
want like I want like the Mike Post
theme song to go on any that because
that sound like the intro to the 18 it's
like he has for its entire life but
driven by the news and now he's brought
the news to you if you can find him
perhaps you can hire the B team thank
you no worries man I pity the fool who
stopped to tell that joke give us the
[ __ ] news mark there's a joker movie
[ __ ] yes there is man look I don't want
to be this guy but I'm just gonna take
this moment to be like I [ __ ] said
from the beginning everyone was like oh
my god is a bad idea we don't need a
joker movie [ __ ] there's it I was like I
don't know this could be a really [ __ ]
cool thing and based on the [ __ ]
press that come out of the Venice Film
Festival where Joker had its world
premiere it got an eight-minute standing
ovation and [ __ ] apparently the movie is
[ __ ] good I've read a few reviews
which I kind of regret cuz they told me
some [ __ ] I didn't necessarily want to
know but I'm a STONER so I'm sure I'll
forget by the time I see it but all the
reviews I read man were like [ __ ]
insanely positive not just like there's
a pretty good comic book movie like
excuse me the term revolutionary was
thrown around I mean it's it seems to
have hit the world
in a big bad way and everybody who has
seen it seems to be responding to it yes
I haven't seen it all I saw was that
most recent trailer which looks great
fantastic Charlotte we saw one trailer
the first one or teaser I'll know what
they're calling it with his mom in it
this one not a lot of mom but more the
rest of the story and it seems prescient
it looks like it's set in the late 70s
early 80s but it seems like it could be
set kind of right now man yeah I mean I
I will reserve judgment until I see the
movie and I'm trying like [ __ ] hell
to get to see this movie mm-hmm
I will say this I remember loving Fight
Club the first time I saw it okay
do you need some lemons a water you know
the water Jason good laughter it was
great the first time I saw it
in 1996 I think it first came out okay
and I saw Fight Club
yeah 99 there it is another one 99 yeah
I saw it again last year and it shocked
me how much today it plays like how to
to build a domestic terrorist like it is
nothing but finally social misfits these
guys who don't fit in give him something
to believe in give them something to
root against give them give them a cause
and unleash them on the world to just
wreak havoc well that's what that movie
is and the Joker might be the greatest
comic book cinematic achievement we've
ever seen but it also could be
incredibly misguided for the time that
we're living really it could be like if
apparently from what I can tell this
joker is a guy who's got some mental
health issues who gets beat up a bunch
of times and then decides to kill people
so it sounds like a taxi driver right
which again if you watch today it's like
Oh lots of people get beat up all the
time
like I got beat up riding the subway in
New York I did not turn into a raving
maniac and that that's what it takes
that's all it takes
Joker the Joker and there's this idea
that because Society has not valued you
we are going to celebrate your lack of
value by
how championing the fact that you're a
maniac like the Joker's the hero of this
movie even as a tragedy he's the hero of
this movie about him
it is sympathetic to him and and there
may be something slippery about putting
that kind of figure at the center of
this kind of movie at this time I don't
know I haven't seen it I can't say for
sure but it looks amazing but but that's
all I got because I look data all I have
is I don't know like yeah you know
that's just it it's me in a place that
when after the last shooting somebody
was like you know these [ __ ] video
games I'm like are you [ __ ] kidding
me like during a video game in the world
that's gonna [ __ ] make somebody do
something like that and I can't a man I
feel the same way about movies they
always try to throw movies under the bus
speaking of the matrix before matrix
happened right around the same time as
come on if I remember correctly or just
before and stuff dudes in trench coats
and whatnot so lots of guns so you know
there's I just don't I never seen a
correlation my entire life between movie
violence and [ __ ] real-life violence
and so I can't imagine it's gonna start
with this particularly when and I'd
taken anything away from this movie at
all but it seems to owe a lot to taxi
driver and if taxi driver didn't create
a nation of taxi drivers they created a
nation of uber drivers now if it didn't
create a nation of taxi drivers I don't
think the Joker is gonna create a nation
of Joker I don't think it's the kind of
thing are you worried that it's giving
the what do they call it the in cell
movement a hero a little bit in that you
know like movies do not incite people to
do real-world actions but they do create
within people a sense of camaraderie a
sense of familiarity a sense of I feel
scene in a way that I have not seen felt
seen before I mean and sometimes it's
great sometimes it's black panther
sometimes it's oh [ __ ] I am now centered
in this movie in a way I've never been
centered before
I am I am a little afraid that this
movie makes Center people who are
centered all the time and in such a way
that rewards them for being this kind of
person I again I don't have any data I
don't have I don't have I haven't seen
the movie so I can't say for sure it
sounds a little alarmist I feel like
they're presenting him he's a bad guy
the whole [ __ ] world knows Joker's a
bad guy so even if he's presented some
what is the antihero it's still like
you're seeing year one of the guy who
goes on to you know [ __ ] masked
murder so many people I don't think
anybody's gonna be like like I am The
Joker doesn't feel like that although
there's a lot of moments in this trailer
of like where you are all clowns and
[ __ ] like that yeah I mean I may very
well be alarmist I would not not calling
you alarmist but I said that that sounds
a little oh that's there but had this
been ten years ago yeah then they gotta
given a [ __ ] but now right now in this
moment in this place at this time like
it is a hair concerning for a black dude
in America
I'm just saying fair enough but it could
also be fantastic I have no problem with
art that's uncomfortable yeah I have no
problem with art that pushes you in ways
that you're not expecting to be pushed
I'm not I have no problem with
provocative cinema hmm I'm just saying
it could do a thing that I don't
necessarily want it to do good I can't
like if you can point to a precedent and
cinema where that ever happened before
it might be Mike I might be able to like
see what you're talking about but I
triumph of the will
come on force that movie today and well
yeah one didn't incite the other we even
cited all of it you know what jaws mate
great Nate Gonzales Dark Knight Returns
as saying more sharks died after jaws
came out and
scene 75 that is absolutely [ __ ] true
i but were they they didn't die because
people will like kill those [ __ ] yeah
what is it I know I know Benchley the
regretted writing Spielberg has also
been like oh man I've when I something
like if I go to like when I die God
better not be a shark or some [ __ ] like
that but I you know I don't say people
don't kill sharks just to be I'm sure
there's sport fishermen but people don't
like that [ __ ] movie made me kill you
[ __ ] you like they're a bunch of people
that kill sharks for [ __ ] shark fin
soup and stuff and less about jaws but
you're right technically those numbers
did go up after Jaws and I it created a
[ __ ] definite bias in me like in as
much as I do view sharks through a very
dark prism and any time everyone's like
no the shark is a beautiful natural bro
like [ __ ] you he tried to kill the whole
Brody family man it was personal no I
mean I will say that after the Six
Million Dollar Man fought Bigfoot we
haven't seen a Bigfoot good point yeah I
don't I don't know let's talk about
something fun goddamn it about that
trailer in the trailer you watch the new
trailers yes we see clowns running amok
and spoilers if you haven't seen the
trailer and this is all just speculation
[ __ ] look like Thomas Wayne and his wife
and his kid rushing out of a theater in
the midst of that melee so do you I saw
that and I was like oh [ __ ] we're gonna
get a spin on the Batman origin but then
I read a review and variety and they
said that the Wayne parents scene hones
close to Nolan's version so I was like
alright so maybe it's not that I like
any movie that makes me watch the
trailer and try to build the rest of the
movie in my mind some Charlie's just
watching like alright that's good you
move on and ship that one has me going
who maybe this is this and this is this
and another example is him
going out at the end of the trailer he's
like can you introduce me as Joker yeah
and clearly he's gonna make his
appearance on that talk show that Robert
De Niro's character is hosting I cannot
and again I don't know jack or [ __ ] but
when I saw that moment and that's the
end of the trailer all I could think
about was the Dark Knight Returns where
Joker does the David Letterman Show or
letter or whatever with their version of
David Letterman and he's like you know
I've killed I've killed thousands of
people Dave I'm gonna kill everyone in
the studio tonight and everyone's like
laughs and ha and then he [ __ ] gasses
and kills everybody in the [ __ ]
studio so I would lay dollars to [ __ ]
doughnuts that he kills everybody in
that [ __ ] studio once he goes on the
other side of that curtain and I am so
[ __ ] in for that movie I know you got
concerns but holy [ __ ] [ __ ] man so
feels like a love letter to source easy
like it is nothing but King of Comedy
yeah I think about [ __ ] taxi driver
yeah to the point we get [ __ ] DeNiro
like like yeah I'm happy for Todd
Phillips I'm now we're finding out more
about the how the movie got me and it
took him a year to convince Warner
Brothers to do it and you know I guess
one of the concerns is like you're not a
comic book guy and that always tends to
work out you know in cinema you don't
need a comic book person to make a comic
book movie man you need a storyteller to
tell a story and they found a new way to
tell a story that well we know part of
and we don't know a lot of and a lot of
people objected to the idea of even
knowing what that story is but now
seeing what the presenting is like I'm
on [ __ ] board man I'm happy for Todd
I'm happy for [ __ ] Joaquin Jesus
Christ if that dude don't want an Oscar
[ __ ] oh he'll win you know right he
will because it's not only does he seem
to be doing a fantastic job but it does
that thing where it's now like the most
acting in addition to the best acting
yeah like oh no I lost 52 pounds to do
this and I had to like figure out how to
do this laughs and it almost broke me
and I couldn't escape the carrot like
all of the things that like the
catterick thing ding-ding-ding you
wonder
what a scare like it is it is catnip
he's gonna win he's gonna [ __ ] win
that's huge particularly for comic book
movies in general and it also probably
game-changing and as much as now you
know people are gonna be like oh [ __ ]
you could do this yeah it feels like
what's what feels weird though is it
feels like you know and this is not me
criticizing but it feels like if you
look at the nolan stuff and then you
look at the trailer for this you're like
oh these things one it felt like we were
on our way to that but then all of a
sudden they were like wait we got to
build the universe man and then they
tried that and then they're like [ __ ] we
ruined it and so then they were like get
the guy from the [ __ ] from the the
hangover movies let him do what he
wanted to do that sounds cool and it
looks like it's gonna work out so I
think you're gonna get a lot of
standalone movies that have no
interconnectivity but just are made by
interesting filmmakers great filmmakers
and stuff and pulling in great [ __ ]
talent if the DC Cinematic Universe is
now nothing but Elseworlds
I'm [ __ ] here for that lucky but just
like alternate takes on [ __ ] that you
kind of know coming from people you
wouldn't expect to get them from mmm
[ __ ] yeah just make it interesting make
it [ __ ] weird make it make it kids
really make a serial killer movie make
it an Aquaman movie make it whatever the
[ __ ] you want but just like live and die
by the I'm gonna trust this film they're
gonna tell this story I don't need a
universe we can't win in that game
anymore it's over but we can win
with really smart [ __ ] shots looks
like they're gonna man that movie was
not expensive I remember when they
announced it they were like oh it's like
a fifty million dollar movie so they're
gonna tag the [ __ ] up they're gonna make
so much [ __ ] money like if your
market your cost is that you can for the
studio would be delighted because like
only [ __ ] we got a comic book movie that
we know is gonna make money is probably
gonna we'll get [ __ ] awards and it
didn't cost us that much to make so we
can [ __ ] overspend on marketing man
cuz normally it takes this much to get
there so they'll spend at least fifty if
not a hundred [ __ ] open it on that
worldwide and it'll just rake in the
[ __ ] dough plus the awards
I can't wait man's [ __ ] it was great
news to see all that [ __ ] happy for all
those kids so weird though cuz instantly
when I saw the trailer and read the
reviews I was like I wonder what the
sequel will be a
I haven't even seen the Puckett movie
and I'm like I wonder what's next yeah I
think Joaquin said like I am in no rush
to do this again and I know Todd
Phillips has an idea for what to do next
how amazing is that one [ __ ] scene
the moment not seeing within the trailer
where he's walking out and he does that
[ __ ] like Joker laughs but then just
turns it off in the review I read
spoilers has been on one another [ __ ]
couriers it's not that spoilery but that
laugh is a Tourette's eat kind of thing
for him that he just does he has a bunch
of laughs that he just nervously doesn't
punctuates conversation with that's why
people like this guy's weird and [ __ ] so
there's like a logic to it as opposed to
like he just became the Joker and
started laughing and [ __ ] like laughing
and that and fake huge laughter is like
something that he involuntarily does
interesting [ __ ] idea man I'm on
board yeah I cautious but interested
yeah I don't feel as cautious I don't I
don't know it doesn't feel irresponsible
to me it feels timely feels like holy
[ __ ] this is a mirror and we're gonna
see something familiar in it and it's
gonna be weird because a lot of people
don't expect that from a comic book
movie so let's see fingers crossed but
[ __ ] man I'm glad I'm glad that I've
worked out should I'm glad that people
are liking it another good comic book
movie means more good comic book movies
down the line amen
speaking of Batman yeah remember a year
ago I'd be a little less we had a
big-ass conversation about whether or
not Batman could be a black guy yes he
has
you know what DC is doing are they doing
black man yeah really that is that is
the the rumor du jour is that in 2021
they're going to introduce a black
Batman it will not be Bruce Wayne okay
they don't they haven't said yet which
character is going to be whether it's
going to be Lucius Fox's son whether
it's going to be
might be black lightning which feels
[ __ ] weird but they want somebody
else in the cape and cowl and they want
that person to be of African descent
thoughts I am fine with it
coming right you know I thought your
thoughts are gonna be like they owe us
money imma be like you're [ __ ] right I
mean my problem had always been that
like oh no you can put a different
character in that suit than called a
Batman then it's fine
but retconning Bruce Wayne as
african-american to me didn't quite
track tell him why because this is
really interesting and it's actually
very smart because Bruce Wayne as the
character exists is a child of privilege
and as a child of old money and as a
child of the people who basically
created Gotham City like the landed
gentry you got kicked out of England for
being [ __ ] Protestant or whatever
that [ __ ] was about the rebels from the
Revolutionary War who finally landed
here and built a town there was a
Carnegie's and Rockefellers and all the
robber barons of American history that
person is not african-american that
person kind of has to be white and the
responsibility the guilt that comes
generationally of that character who has
benefited from centuries of theft and
and sort of wrapping their arms around a
country that may or may not have
deserved it or wanted it or and and the
the sort of subjugation of certain
people's for the elevation of others
that guy the son of that guy is the one
who decides like oh [ __ ] I'm responsible
for what Gotham is from a from a genetic
way and so I feel like I need to do what
I can to fix it and I'm also kind of
crazy and so I'm gonna punch it in the
face rather than you know invest in
infrastructure and like schools don't
[ __ ] ruin it with [ __ ]
infrastructure and [ __ ] and they built a
train I saw that one
and then if David came to no good really
did but so that idea that that that
guilt
thatthat societal guilt that
generational guilt is part of what makes
Bruce Wayne down the cape and cowl to
begin with and there are no
african-americans that have that history
in America to the point where they feel
responsible for a see it just doesn't
exist old money old black money doesn't
really exist in that way so the people
who have been rich for a while like the
Johnsons who owned be to you like that's
real money geez he's the [ __ ]
billionaire but he does not feel
responsible in that same way for Oh
everything that's wrong with this city
is because my father's father's father's
mother's father [ __ ] it up from the
jump jay-z's like I got 99 problems but
a bad ain't one that's a thing so yeah
that was always my reasoning and and the
idea that you could just race Bantu
Bruce Wayne for me felt wrong in a way
where you can race been James Bond all
you want all he's got to do is be a
[ __ ] orphan you could technically the
waste bin Peter Parker if you want all
he's got to do is be from a broken home
in Queens like there's actually no good
reason why that kid is white and not
like any of the other like maybe eight
different versions of immigrants that
you get in New York right but there's
just something about [ __ ] Bruce Wayne
who he's got to be that guy but if
you're gonna just put some make up a new
character and that guy gets to wear the
cape and cowl like he did with a Jean
Paul valet like they did with you know
any number of people who have over the
years [ __ ] Dick Grayson was Batman
for a heartbeat
looking apparently James Gordon was
Batman and is Batman for a heartbeat in
in Tom King books so yeah go for it make
a new character give a guy a shot how do
you feel feel Greg because the you know
people push it here free to sign and
[ __ ] and this person did the [ __ ] who is
this Joshua Montel from o77 oh [ __ ]
that's back home Jersey style where are
you well done
not marburo holy [ __ ] mark you remember
you know yeah my old zip code was zero
seven seven four six seven right now
yeah I was [ __ ] I'm three two I grew
up
and then Red Bank is oh one but more
importantly like he included a letter so
I want to open it because I always pull
out the sleeve too sudden sleeve and he
wrote dear mr. Smith this is how you
write I'll start a [ __ ] letter kids
dear mr. Smith here's a premium sativa
blunt to thank you for being such an
icon and inspiration well done man
Joshua that's how you do it man you give
me some weed I'm like I'll sign anything
I'll sign your dick now what do you want
[Applause]
I'm very [ __ ] sweet anyway alright so
they're gonna make a black Batman we
know nothing about it other than it's
gonna happen they made this announcement
haven't they make kind of announcement
hey kids you know did you like this
fight overs welcome to the bad first oh
my god you're right they're like we're
gonna take Batman on a trip for miles
get it yeah thank you don't even take
that groaner you know you're living your
best life today me I really am
what are the news do we got that is a
[ __ ] well-made blunt man well done
damn I was smoking that tonight hi my
wife I'm gonna wake my wife up at 11:30
she be like who gave you weed what are
you doing we did not have one Batman
story this week we didn't have two
Batman stories this week everybody at
home was like y'all [ __ ] never
talk about Batman on your fat man beyond
shoulders kind of fam Alabama I've three
Batman news stories three in a row three
in a [ __ ] row feels great man it's a
good time to be a Batman fan what do you
got what's the third story Robert
Pattinson did a his first interview for
a variety since he was cast as Batman
and had some [ __ ] to say someone was
interesting some was just like you know
rich pretty actor talking about stuff
but let me see when I was a kid Batman
was the only outfit that I had this
Robert Pattinson soffits Hansen said
that in an interview setting some minion
just over here I'm at a Starbucks or
some
yeah he's totally eloquent fair enough
if I'd said an interview I would
definitely have a lot of abuse
afterwards but if I successfully play
the character I can say so at the end
bla bla bla bla bla this is an inspiring
confidence I'll be honest with you I was
looking for a little more eloquence and
[ __ ] yeah he had a meeting with Marvel
around the time when he's not Batman
incorrectly mark it seems to be out of
meeting with marvel for guardians of the
galaxy mm-hmm but nothing came of it so
he was not opposed to doing the
superhero thing no but I wonder who he
would have played Ronan maybe no he
would at that point he was [ __ ]
famous he was the boy from the Twilight
he's sparkly vampire boy there's no way
they like play the character nobody
remembers his [ __ ] name the guy with
the hammer that's not Thor like I'm sure
they were going for you know Peter Peter
quill right I mean who else Nakamura
unless they had a real different idea of
what's a good character but let's say he
talks about he got the job when he was
shooting Christopher Nolan's tenant his
like weird gloss on the James Bond spy
thing and he was able to then talk to
Nolan about playing Batman what does
Christopher Nolan's tenens that what
he's doing now yeah it's coming out I
want to say next summer but it's a big
spider it's the movie he's making right
now f is post Dunkirk movie and it's
called what Tennant why did you know
that I don't know that when did they
announce this [ __ ] really
David announced the title I remember
them saying like he's someone making
another movie I was like well that's a
foregone conclusion they never said what
it was there was a trailer that I think
he's not online you could only see it if
you went to a 35 millimetres showing of
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood
oh [ __ ] that ain't too pretentious
[Applause]
sorry where'd that come from I was sorry
not normally that caddie my bad yeah
somebody's got his sassy pants on today
but yeah so he was able to talk about
you know sort of the the pressures of
being Batman the responsibility of the
suit all of that stuff eloquent as you
would think a British guy would be more
or less though it says he sound like the
good choice I like him as an actor and
[ __ ] and I look forward to this movie
the lighthouse man a big bad way yeah I
think he's a good choice I know he
doesn't like you know maybe look the
part I guess traditionally speaking
because he seems like a lanky kid but
you know that you know Batman's all
[ __ ] suit right mmm and you know when
you're not in the suit you gotta [ __ ]
be like I'm tortured and he did that
it's why light for [ __ ] decades and
[ __ ] so I'm sure he'll be able to pull
this off in his sleep yeah but have you
heard what the story is I have it now I
mean the rumors was it was long
Halloween
what do you why yeah I think I'm not
wrong I think you're collecting the
information slip tonight that I didn't
know the tenant and I didn't never heard
that where are you getting this
information I said the rumor was that it
was long Halloween really yes you know
to hell he knows it's the first time oh
you got two sources you and that guy
to be fair I heard it too I heard and I
heard it from a good source too as did I
cannot it blew my mind man and [ __ ] but
you saw how I reacted when mark did
remember that come Oscar time that's all
I'm saying
for your consideration um yeah I heard
that and I'd found cream my jeans I'm
like are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me and
they're like yeah that's the word I'm
like then I stopped breathing and [ __ ]
yeah can't wait that'd be fun that's it
but we don't know if that's it we don't
know no we don't at all apparently damn
all right three Batman's stories three
men stories but I got another DC story
oh [ __ ] we're still a DC Universe yeah
things are happening Suicide Squad
they're adding members of that cast like
you won't [ __ ] believe the great
James Gunn is directing Suicide Squad
ours our wonderful friend Dave de small
chin is in it and then are they bringing
Oh Margo Roby's in it Margo Roby Idris
Elba Idris Elba but he's not playing
he's not replacing Will Smith as
Deadshot he's playing a completely new
character yeah Deadshot's not returning
I mean as Will Smith but not but not
even as a character if I understand
correctly
apparently we still get Jai Courtney and
Joel Kinnaman hold on so that means
you're getting boomerang Captain
Boomerang and Rick Flagg
yes Viola Davis is back that's she was
good well very good
let's see Steve Agee is bling king shark
whoo Steve Agee yeah yeah the one who is
in the the Guardians movie yeah yeah
he's playing King shark king shark
that's cool yeah yeah he's tall he could
pull that off because they just built
like you know [ __ ] CG over him right
but we're also absolutely gonna get
Taika Waititi in that movie you know
cause he knows James Caan yes okay as
unrevealed as of yet Peter Capaldi
doctor who is also gonna be in the movie
he's also going to be in the movie
nathan fillion from slither he knows
whether he was in guardians he was in
super he's been a super that's right
wait what was the in guardians he is
he thought he didn't make the cut he's
in now he's easy he's not in guardians
to be Wonder Man in the poster in the
back Guardians one he plays a CG
character who a costs it's in a prison
sequence I was there and he's like a
costing Gamora when she first comes in
and she and like drags doesn't they then
bill yeah I didn't know that all right
so he's gonna be in Suicide Squad yes
those three deaf community and who do
you think he could be playing oh my god
if I this is just I don't know [ __ ] you
don't know [ __ ] about [ __ ] but let's
just play around right because it's
[ __ ] fun Suicide Squad they're
[ __ ] around with it set in the DC
Universe ain't nobody married to anymore
continuity and [ __ ] like that
you know this guy's Batman and that
ain't Ben Affleck and this guy's the
Joker not ain't that person what if
Nathan Fillion is playing Batman that
would be [ __ ] genius casting it would
be it's not that though right or Green
Lantern which is actually played like
nine times on the various animated
movies you might be onto something
because based on a little information
that I know from a [ __ ] undetermined
source that that would play hmm wow wow
I didn't even thought of that
[ __ ] you always make a better movie I'm
sorry where were you when I was Megan
reboot [ __ ] I was asleep in the crew
yeah it's true you were there
[ __ ] man alright well that makes me more
excited for that movie I think it's be
amazing and apparently Pete Davidson is
also gonna play like an extended cameo
in Suicide Squad Yeah right on
Jesus this is shaping up man I mean I
was onboard the moment they said James
Gunn but god dammit gun just keeps
firing man over and over
thank you Wow sorry you are on three
gold like while we have this moment
before you go into the next story we
were given two pens yours is back there
- here robot rabbit collectibles and
it's a rabbit robot who made this whose
is this
this is an adorable logo what is it what
woody wood is robot robot rabbit what a
great idea why didn't anybody ever do
this before like make a robot looks
mechanical and [ __ ] that's good it's
[ __ ] a good idea right there man it's
cute looking at [ __ ] that's really cool
man is it a comic book or where can they
find this holy [ __ ] there's gonna be a
long story though I was just looking for
a URL go ahead he's got the Mike JC got
a mine so I I formed this company this
year and basically I form a partnership
with my comic shop and I'm selling toys
and other collectibles in that pin right
now on eBay and then by the end of the
year hopefully I'll have my own website
and but robot rabbit has been my alter
ego for a long time
I'm robot rabbit and I have had this
idea in my head for these characters
forever and the ultimate goal is to make
action figures out of them
how can a man oh it's adorable give it
up for robot rabbit right
entrepreneurial we must have more news
than that we do indeed okay what else I
have a kit watch man has a release date
final trailers for that look pretty good
yeah October 20th October 20th we get to
see it tic tac toe be on the road for
the Jay and Silent Bob reboot Roadshow
where will you be in a jumper 20 on the
20th I leave I'll be in Chicago I think
the 19th we kick off the tour in New
Jersey and then the next night we're in
Chicago I think so I'll be in Chicago
for that good for you I have no news
just that's happening and I think a
quick sweep up of the [ __ ] that we
missed while we were gone
specifically there's stuff that broke at
d23 oh my god that's right we didn't get
to talk about like last weekend
Disney had their version of comic-con
which they called d23 what does that
mean yeah they're 23 inch long did know
it I was sitting there going oh my god
does it what is that I think it's like
1923 was the premiere of the first
Mickey Mouse cartoons anybody into this
[ __ ] anybody vouch for that
steelwill worst year to steamboat
willies 1923 cents d23 there you go that
was pretty close yeah yeah not bad I
mean it seems like a weird you know I
guess whatever it's a name but like it
always seemed crazy to me but now it
makes sense
chi-ching that's you're right that's why
I mean [ __ ] they know how to Qing don't
they
Jesus Christ and it seems as if as ever
our forecasting prognosticating skills
are on point ooh
because Marvel announced three TV shows
that we said that they should announce
yes during the z23 we just got a bunch
of announcements at Comic Con where
Kevin Feige went up and showed us the
big board and said this is phase three
four four this is phase four
[ __ ] and laid out the whole
world instead of now TV shows a part of
it too on the Disney Plus app and [ __ ]
and we thought that was it like I was
like well that's a [ __ ] ton of
information they won't say anything for
a few more years and then d23 they're
like oh you think that's a lot of dick
here's some more and people were
tripping over it man is crazy how many
[ __ ] shows they were announced and
tell them what they announced they
announced MS marvel Jesus like that's
[ __ ] that's incredible and they've
also said that it's not just going to be
on Disney Plus they're putting her in
the movies as well yes I think there's
there's going to be a lot of back and
forth as is what is it Kamala Khan mhm
as the first Muslim superhero and
they're doing it this is a live-action
show yes
all these are live-action she-hulk
amazing got a great [ __ ] idea tell
you the world where it's like you can't
do a Hulk show [ __ ] do she-hulk man
that's pretty awesome keep the brand
alive and that's great character on her
own having nothing to do with [ __ ]
Bruce Banner and stuff
I think this is a lawyer Ram yeah
Jennifer Walters yeah I think there's a
lovely little groundswell of support for
rosario Dawson as Josefa Walter oh my
god
yeah I mean look number one put her in
everything but number two yeah I mean
yeah yeah I mean that looks when she's
the halt they're gonna yes simply you're
out and stuff so yeah I think I think
she'd be amazing and and I think the one
that made you the happiest was midnight
[ __ ] that was crazy man it was crazy
that all of a sudden they were like oh
by the way new night like it was
unbelievably [ __ ] beautiful and
that's gonna be an exploit their spare
no expense on these shows no so it's not
even like like Oh moon night on TV it'll
be like they're gonna make it look like
a [ __ ] movie moon night for those
that don't follow this kind of [ __ ] is
like Marvel's Batman more or less if
they're doing they think they're doing
the mark
what's-his-name marks doctor version
[ __ ] man that's gonna be dope and he's
got a cool costume mm-hmm really cool I
can't wait to see that rendered again
live-action live-action I'm on board for
all of that what else they announced
they're they announced that Black
Panther 2 is officially coming but not
until 2021 oh my god thought you know
what I'll take it
oh sorry 2022 may 6 20 22 oh well now we
riot Wow
[ __ ] well gives us something to look
forward to but that sounds smells like
three years away no it does he just
turned in a treatment ryan coogler who
was there says that gave him the
treatment for what I want the movie to
be now they got to write it make it so
this is the one where weren't we
thinking it might have no more in it yes
the Submariner mm-hmm to be amazing
they didn't say nothing like that though
they would not reveal the title or the
identity of the villain just yet it's on
the rise it's so crazy cuz you're like
oh man but we just saw Black Panther but
Black Panther happened a while back and
then we had two Avenger movies that he
was in since then so I mean will he be
in anything else prior to Black Panther
to what
I mean it wouldn't hold on that was said
with such certainty is that Kevin Feige
yeah what would he be in before that do
you know something we don't
are you sitting on the information we'll
talk after the show I mean I think that
there's a world in which you could
definitely be in Falcon and Winter
Soldier because there's a tie definitely
to Winter Soldier because that character
was the white wolf just family just
[ __ ] broke my brain I'm like they
could do that wait and they will
probably because yeah like they're all
they're treating them like movies anyway
wow that was great man oh yeah this
[ __ ] Disney Plus is everything I
signed up for it did you I did because
they were running this crazy [ __ ]
deal which is now over but it was like a
Founders Day deal where during d23 up
until September 2nd if you joined d23
which is their fan club you could join
for free you could get a little like
voucher code or whatever that knocked
off like 30 percent of the fee for every
year basically you could sign up for
three years for $150 Wow and if I
remember correctly Netflix is like fifty
ninety-nine a month so basically for for
the same amount of money you get three
years of Disney Plus and one year of
Netflix [ __ ] there's a lot of math
that's a lot of [ __ ] out but like
three years man just when you're [ __ ]
subscription runs out black panther -
yep but yeah they are doing their best
to [ __ ] [ __ ] Netflix I mean they
boy they're I don't know if they're
trying to [ __ ] Netflix as much as get
us to buy and they got me they had me at
you know [ __ ] a lone ship but then
they started announcing what they're
doing and I'm like I saw a [ __ ]
trailer for a Bill Hader movie with
what's-her-name Anna Kendrick that
looked like Paul Dinis [ __ ] jingle
bell it's called Noel and she's like
Santa Claus his daughter and Bill
hader's Santa Clauses son he's taken
over for Santa Claus but you don't want
to be Santa Claus and [ __ ]
look Laos watching the trailer going
like oh this must be an SNL joke or
something like [ __ ] the nobody did
they make this movie and it's literally
like coming in November like they've
been making movies secretly on the Qt
and [ __ ] just for [ __ ] Disney Plus
lady in the [ __ ] that was another
trailer all of a sudden I'm like holy
[ __ ] they did lady in the [ __ ] getting
these dogs to try and [ __ ] that
spaghetti and scenes gonna look weird
[Music]
but they're so smart though like [ __ ]
why not like nobody else gonna make lady
in the [ __ ] nobody else can they can
they can put it on their [ __ ] thing
and people like [ __ ] I'll watch that man
they're smart I mean I know they know
that but they're gonna make a lot of
money a lot of money even if they break
you lose there's my hot take for the
week this Disney do like they're gonna
do well they're also making their
carving some space out of California
Adventure and I think doing similar in
Florida and in Paris doing an Avengers
campus saw that there's gonna be a whole
Marvel land my biggest question is what
does that mean for in Universal Florida
they got marvel islands of adventure I
don't know I don't know what that deal
is I don't know how long that deal lasts
so do you think it ends a certain point
and then marvel at Disney's like no
thanks we'll take our characters back
yeah what is it it is more based on the
comic book stuff you're very true very
right so they'll let that license keep
going maybe or they'll pull it back if
if I'm Disney I'm like [ __ ] you we just
spent what 75 billion to [ __ ] buy the
x-men characters you think we're gonna
let universal theme parks have a Marvel
land
[ __ ] you that means there's gonna be a
lot of open real estate in Marvel's
islands of adventure at Universal
Studios Florida so I [ __ ] say Jay and
Silent Bob land is fully
fully licensed of all and available and
you don't even have to make big stupid
like [ __ ] foam characters of us me
and J will show the [ __ ] up ride
rollercoasters that'd be amazing I can't
wait to walk on the Avengers campus but
I'll be honest with you a couple years
ago I was like I can't wait to go to
galaxy's edge and I could because I
still haven't gone yet so I'm part of
the problem field trip yeah but I don't
you know I'm I'll be there soon but I'll
definitely be there on day one for this
year they are also in Walt Disney World
Resort in Florida building the Star Wars
galactic star cruiser yeah that's the
big hotel [ __ ] hotel it's an
immersion experience they finally gave
out more details basically it's a
three-day package or like two days three
nights or whatever the [ __ ] they're
saying is gonna be like 1,100 1400 per
person and you go into a building and
it's like dinner theater it's like you
know [ __ ] murder mystery theater for
two and a half days kylo Ren is coming
and he's gonna board and [ __ ] like
that happens like day two or whatever
the [ __ ] everyone's wearing costumes
can't dress like us normal you gotta
[ __ ] dress up like in that world
there are no [ __ ] windows to the
outside world whatsoever once you enter
the property you're immersed and so the
windows in your room are TV screens you
don't join monitors and they're just
showing you space outside so it's like
it's not like hey man I'm gonna go and I
want a vacation let's go to that Star
Wars hotel this is a [ __ ] trip in and
of itself that you can't like leave and
go to Disney World [ __ ] although there's
an underground tram system that brings
you to the you know the Star Wars
Millennium Falcon ride at galaxy's edge
but they don't let you walk in the park
and interact with normies and [ __ ]
because you're wearing the clothes
you're in the world and [ __ ] so they
tunnel you in and then tunnel you out
like they're really put their head wrap
their head around this man I can't think
of anybody that's done something like
this because it feels illegal
we're gonna kidnap you for three days
and you're gonna pay us to do it and we
may or may not kill you and sacrifice
you to raise the body of [ __ ] Walt
Disney from the grave how many souls
will it take 1,400 bucks a person
doesn't sound like a vacation it sounds
like a paycation man like that sounds
[ __ ] expensive however three days of
an experience like your you'll go home
and be like [ __ ] kylo Ren walked into
our bedroom and she could you imagine
being a kid and being able to tell your
friends like kylo Ren came into my room
like no he didn't you're like look at my
[ __ ] phone [ __ ] you just sat at the
edge of badge yeah what are you doing
yeah just [ __ ] I can feel your force
I just want to watch you sleep you look
so peaceful
it's I'm you know again I'm like I can't
wait to go but I bet you I could wait to
go to that but I would go that sounds
kind of cool I just don't know like
you're not in charge of your own life
for three days think it doesn't sound
like you get to go like a man can I go
over you know to Disney for an hour
there look there is no Disney yeah
that's some John Hannon type [ __ ] right
there yeah ah that's true it really oh
my god that's why it's familiar its
jurassic park car Laurens gonna go crazy
I can cut you an ass so [ __ ] well all
the time I'm just saying that's right
it's Westworld
I got I got one last story okay because
take his home but who students at in
Nashville Catholic school will no longer
have access to the Harry Potter series
because there were banned and refused
removed from the library because
apparently these books and I quote
present magic is both good and evil
which is not true but in fact a clever
deception the curses and spells used in
the books are actual curses and spells
which when read by a human being risk
conjuring evil spirits into the presence
of the person reading the text
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me nobody told
me that no no how about i made those
books a lot more enjoyable man go i'm
like let's see if this works so uh so
yeah that that's a new story from today
and not like 75 years ago but sure wow
these people that pulled the book
christian by any chance a catholic yeah
catholic that that's my people yeah we
don't we don't like reading my favorite
part of that whole news story
Rowling could not be reached for comment
really yeah that seems irregular she
seems to comment on anything anytime
anybody's like hey man was Dumbledore
gay she's like not only was he gay let
me tell you how he did it and gives you
details and [ __ ] no I think even she was
like I'm not gonna tag up on this like
just let him do what they're gonna do
I'm sure it means she'll sell more books
ultimately right like probably just
because they're losing them in that
school system don't mean [ __ ] but
yeah they can't get them anywhere
somebody gave me a gift I want to open
it but there's so much tape mr. Kevin
Smith happy belated bday who gave me
this
don't even [ __ ] joke man because it's
gonna be Kevin Smith died in a bar
unnamed a black person also day says
Morgan I enter heaven marks like I told
you that Joker movie was gonna be
trouble
somebody dropped it off and then didn't
come to this show somebody dropped it
off and [ __ ] off and you let me open
it JC MOTU and pop stuff bonus Robin and
the Dreamweavers and then there's a card
with a happy belated birthday
big dork I checked it for anthrax and
things just wasn't sticking cordially
Pat Jackson and a guy and he gave me his
email Jose was a cute dog on me oh hey
Pat it comes to the show he said he's
good you could vouch for this vote for
him [ __ ] hang well thanks Pat but Wow
for a minute there was really exciting
right like alright well and what is this
somebody said hi Kevin the portrait on
the board is for you to keep the loose
one is for an autograph and this is from
Taylor and let's see the one on the
board love instructions I'm a director
so I really respected that man was like
that's [ __ ] thorough I walked in on
the oh the one on the board is mine and
this one I'm signing who do get you did
this [ __ ] a man what it is that a
drawing a digital painting [ __ ] well
done I was gonna say like holy [ __ ] that
looks like me I'm signing a loose one to
anybody or just tagging it was the name
tail oh that's right I just read it
hold on Taylor what's your name no and I
get to keep the other one on the board
oh my god my wife's gonna love this like
it yet another [ __ ] picture of you
Kevin I swear she's a fan oh that's
really nice man thank you I'll put that
up here is there anything I didn't sign
on can you pass me that [ __ ] and then
what's this thing the action stars
anybody who pouches for this what's the
story there JC will give you a Mike the
action stars at the action stars what is
it
we're on social media we're just trying
to make people laugh with action figures
Oh [ __ ] a right on man like [ __ ]
what they used to do in wizard magazine
Toy Fair should or goblin machen effort
reference like they do on Robot Chicken
it's a little more current just like in
the 90s they did that you're like bro
they still do it today that's really
cool man this dude wanted us to sign
this and not apparently steal his
identity which has his like bank card
and license inside this is one of those
theft proof things right like it can't
get like they can't steal your [ __ ]
codes or whatever and they can if you
just put it on somebody's bar
[Applause]
this one says please make to Scully holy
[ __ ] my dead dog's name was Scully
is it you who's Scully hey man is that
your real name was it a last name of
something [ __ ] a how popular were you
when that show was on the air I remember
I had a dog named Scully ID Mulder and
Scully we were big fans of the x-files
and [ __ ] and so whenever we'd watch the
show you know they always set each
other's names all sound like Mulder
Scully and the dogs ability
it was almost as entertaining as expose
all right is everything signed yeah
about that thing this is a box of cards
if you tag everyone all right we're done
with the news yes we are that mean give
it up for mark you gave me other news
[Applause]
now we come to the part of the show
ladies and gentlemen that folks like and
seemed to like it's the Q&A portion of
the show man where we open it up to you
the good folks in the audience and you
get to ask some questions and if you ask
some really cool questions you walk away
with one of these three fabulous prize
bags that's right we're on bags now
pools good folks at 4dx
who have just about the most
entertaining [ __ ] way to watch a
movie a chair that moves and spits that
you and [ __ ] shakes you up and
whatnot you never fall asleep one of
their movies because you know start
going out and all of a sudden like by
hanging [ __ ] great way to watch a movie
our friend Brett Deakin has been given
us tickets for a long long time and
stuff from the good folks at 40x and
also what's the other thing
screen X that's how we watched a
spider-man far from home and stuff so as
per usual if you asked if you have if
you get picked and your your questions
good and [ __ ] you're gonna win tickets
two tickets to 40 X you can go see
anything they're probably the next thing
coming up is it it's coming up and did
somebody JC you got friends like it is
scary as [ __ ] was his quote Bret Deakins
direct quote Fred digadz that it is
scariest [ __ ] before chapter 2 is
scary as [ __ ] in 40 X there you go so if
you win these [ __ ] tickets
as froze up assault cameras like Cindy
Brady that's an old reference you win
one of these you can go see it chapter 2
which comes out like in two minutes or
whatever in 40 acts and stuff so how
[ __ ] awesome is that but also what
you'll get from the good folks at Hot
Topic are a bunch of Jane Sound Bob a
reboot Church man so this one's got
movies I'm eatin it t-shirt this one has
a another movie shirt win any movie
stuffy looks like that pull that shirt
down looks like this and then the other
one oh that's a chronic t-shirt of
Bluntman and chronic symbol the actual
chronic logo as designed by mr. Mike
Allred the creator of Mad Men you if you
like these shirts they got good folks at
Hot Topic are doing a [ __ ] ton of shirts
for reboot man and I'm the kind of guy
that like that [ __ ] matters to me
because I wear t-shirts and whatnot and
then I used to never want to wear my
face on my t-shirt size I think that's
gross but like that's marketing so now I
[ __ ] wear my shirts for all the [ __ ]
that I do and whatnot so anytime they
like a we're gonna do a new shirt I'm
like [ __ ] yeah do it
and they made a bunch of shares to go to
Hot Topic comm there's a whole Jay and
Silent Bob reboot section so tonight
you're gonna win a Hot Topic t-shirt
you're gonna win 40 X tickets if you ask
a question that both me and Mark can
answer that's all we ask we don't ask
that you give us a question and [ __ ]
like that that like only one of us can
answer and stuff but JC I guess we've
changed it a little bit like you're we
used to just like pick people at random
and [ __ ] JC came up with a better system
yeah I made a lot of enemies that way so
we're doing how do you why what do you
mean how'd you make enemies because
people like you didn't pick me I mean
there yeah there's this many questions
every night and everybody said we had a
connection I was like I talked to 40
people tonight and they're like but you
and I I and I was like okay we got a we
got a I don't know I don't like being
the bad guy so now what do you have them
do so now we have index cards that
people write questions on before the
show starts and
andrew and i go through them and pick
questions that work with the subject
matter of what we've talked about during
the show and don't repeat week after
week after week
right on alright so streamline there we
go alright so JC has vetted the
questions picked three people and give
us our first victim
Oscar Gonzales Oscar come on up man give
it up for Oscar
this better be good or I'm not giving
you your license back I'm sorry there's
better be good I'm not giving any
license back now I'll be how are you ask
her Walter pretty good bit nervous hi my
question for you guys is um what he has
helped you overcoming difficult it bent
or part in your life and how have you
been able to apply that lesson learned
into your to everyday or when things get
difficult what a great [ __ ] question
number one you win pick a bag go ahead
pick one movie movie chronic nobody
likes movie what a great question you
have one I got one you need to think
like that mine so easy from the hip
luckily I'm not just a person that gets
to watch movies a few times I've gotten
to make them and so the movie that most
helped me out in life was incredibly
therapeutic and did make me a better
person and did get me through hard times
was hands down chasing amy chasing amy
the if you knew me before chasing amy
and then knew me after chase game you
would be like jesus christ he just
[ __ ] grew up over the span of a year
and [ __ ]
that helped me stop being the individual
I was I don't know if it's I always
chalk it up to being Jersey because
Jason Mewes is still the same kind of
way Brian Johnson was the same kind of
way like very we're very jealous like
very like tightly wound I've chalked it
up to years later male sexual insecurity
and [ __ ] like that but we were all a
little bit [ __ ] up about sex not
[ __ ] up in a sinister way but just
like you know you saw chasing amy
[ __ ] Holden I had a real issue with
like wait you had sex with [ __ ] guys
like that whole movie is about well that
whole movies about main security kind of
was an insecurity in security
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah very much so
but yeah if I was if I hold one of all
the characters I've created is the one
that's closest to me
so Holden's journey is kind of my
journey although I was never like we
should all [ __ ] sleep together and
[ __ ] that was something for the movie
but I was that person who felt like oh
my god I created something I created a
little piece art and it traveled and it
gave me a job and [ __ ] you know I'm
I'm [ __ ] liberal-minded and [ __ ] I'm
progressive in mobile and then Holden
just like I was was forced to face the
fact that he's fairly conventional like
at the end of the day even though thinks
of himself it's like hey I'm worldly and
then he meets somebody who's truly
worldly and a completely [ __ ]
challenges his worldview and [ __ ] like
that so that movie make writing that
movie making that movie stopped me from
being that individual helped me grow up
I never could it could have been married
to the woman I've been married to for
the last 20 years if I hadn't made
chasing amy because she had boyfriend's
before me she was even engaged to
somebody before we [ __ ] met and I
know who I was at masse chasing him
that's who I was I would have been so
[ __ ] crazy like about that like
[ __ ] like you know was he better than
me how many dicks did you suck like that
kind of [ __ ] did you see it in the
movies it was part but it stopped at a
certain point like it's in clerks
there's a little bit Mallrats it's
definitely in chasing Amy but it stops
in chasing Amy and then it stopped in my
real life as well like after I get did
chasing amy I was like oh [ __ ] I don't
want like some girlfriend who's like
been in a box or something like that I
want somebody who's worldly who's been
out there is tasted life you're supposed
to learn something in a relationship and
[ __ ] like that it's supposed to be a
little dangerous your heart has to be on
the line you have to feel inadequate
sometimes these are the things that help
grow as an individual and [ __ ] like that
so in making that movie I was able to
like kind of get beyond that I was I
remember after that I was like
you know [ __ ] I might completely
changed my ethos like I was like now I
just want to find people that did a [ __ ]
ton of [ __ ] before I ever met him and
then I met my wife and so it's beautiful
ya know that movie that movie definitely
changed who I was for the better so I
can't think of any movie outside of one
I've made what's my go-to [ __ ]
feel-good movie I honestly don't think I
have one where I'm like I'm just gonna
put this in because it always makes you
feel warm and fuzzy I will like go down
hard and deep on a Marvel movie man like
they make me feel great but I don't have
like you know I had a bad day let me
watch Iron Man I'm just like it's
Tuesday let's watch Iron Man you know
[ __ ] so I I don't have a movie that
like has been my security blanket but
yeah but I did make one you I think I
talked a little bit about my weird
related with Finding Nemo before yes I
do a little bit why so everyone has
context so it's beautiful so when when
my daughter was born I was the nerd who
I was a movie nerd who had like been
collecting DVDs and I had like the
library of [ __ ] [ __ ] that I was gonna
suppose my kids too because that's what
you do when you're a movie lover
here's here's the parts of my
personality that I've managed to collect
and put on the Shelf that I'm going to
slowly film by film by film teach you
who I am through what I love and that
was the plan that was straight up the
plan and and so I had like thousand
[ __ ] movies in the house she's waiting
for her to get old enough to want to dig
into these with me and then by like
eighteen months almost two years old we
realized that developmentally something
wasn't quite firing for her on all
cylinders and and she was diagnosed as
autistic and which you know the the the
experience of being a parent of a
special-needs kid is one of revising
expectations you know like when a kid is
born it's like oh I'm gonna give you the
world
I'm gonna do everything start the
[ __ ] college fund I gotta save up for
your wedding I'm gonna do all this stuff
as that kid develops typically or or a
typically you just begin revising what
those things are but things remain on
the table for your average kid but for
us it was starting to pull things off
the table like okay College probably
isn't in the cards but maybe high school
we'll see you know this but maybe not
that and she her attention span was not
such that she was gonna watch any movie
ever that I put in front of her except
for Finding Nemo is the only movie she
will still watch beginning to end she's
almost 17 years old it's the only movie
she'll watch soup to nuts and so my
relationship to that movie was first one
of like oh we got one you guys you got a
movie she's gonna watch this is great
and then like 40 times are watching
Finding Nemo it's like [ __ ] again with
it just keep swimming
and then like 200 times of watching
friend of Nemo and like 400 times of
watching Finding Nemo because it became
her security blanket like when she's
upset she wants her Nemo phone which is
just like her phone that we just
stripped from everything else and only
loaded Finding Nemo on so that's what
she watched I want my Nemo phone oh my
god I want a Nemo phone and that sounds
amazing right and so my relationship to
that movie is very much tied to my
relationship to my daughter and that
movies fundamentally about a father
realizing who his child actually is and
accepting that child for who he is and
so that movie for me is very much
wrapped in so being a parent and being a
grown-up and rolling with punches and
and never finding a way or choosing to
look differently at somebody love give
it up for my excellent question give it
up for air
[Applause]
well beautiful you're gonna need that
all right JC who's next
Lizzy Mitchell Lizzy give it up for
Lizzy everybody Lizzy come on up Oh
team effort is it you could both come up
if you need to hey hey oh that's a
[ __ ] local accent
we're from the UK were part and just
west of London well I live in Scotland
with my Scottish husband what you got
for us
Lizzy and so if either of you let's
write a screenplay and Kevin if you're
gonna write one for my uncle mark you're
gonna write I was getting and which you
cast the other as a hero or a villain
and also what genre would it be in one
more time if we could make a movie
Carrie
sorry Nietzsche starring each other
would we cast each other as the hero or
the villain and what genre would it be
yes a great [ __ ] question that's
definitely gonna win tickets give it up
for our ladies
[Applause]
also just the accent and lady doing a
bridge decks that took me back to like
JK rowling have no comment but that's
what it would have sounded like all
right so what's the idea here man you
won't go first him now I can go first oh
I think I I would cast okay first it's a
heist movie yeah I think it might be a
heist movie set of the convention yeah
and I think you have is the he's the
Terry Benedict of this particular story
so you're the you're the dude getting
high stood man I'm the dupe I'm the
pigeon you come to mark you're the mark
well yeah I think you're put in the
sequel works out for him you're sorry
but whatever the first one ain't good
enough to get to a [ __ ] sequel and
[ __ ] right it'll be good fair enough
but yeah like I think you have like
let's let's pretend that you have all of
Jack Kirby's pencils for like Fantastic
Four number one okay and you take it on
tour and you're gonna be it [ __ ] in
San Diego comic-con with these twenty
two pieces of comic-book history that
are worth millions of millions of
dollars and it's got to get hoisted from
you
I like it yeah that's and I get to play
Kevin Smith you get to play [ __ ]
Kevin so [ __ ] easy
so genre is hi Chandra hi sir yeah shot
through with a bunch of cool before I
commit to this picture who else is in it
who are the ocean's 11 who are whose
heisted me
well what billion Nathan Fillion as
Batman because I'm in man I remember we
now we had a different idea there was
some podcast a while back years and
years ago where we talked about like San
Diego comic-con San Diego's a military
town and we were wondering why San Diego
the comic-con itself is always without
incident like that is that is a soft
target if ever there was one if you were
like a bad do to want to do bad things
there's a hundred thousand nerds just in
a city full of love and joy and I can't
you shut the [ __ ] up my god between the
Joker and this you're like violence
everyone violence don't [ __ ] tempt
fate come to me my child and and uh and
that the heroes of that particular story
were a bunch of like [ __ ] military
folks who were on leave so like Captain
America is cosplaying as Captain America
basically that's you know there's a
bunch of soldiers dressed up as heroes
who foil whatever [ __ ] crime is
happening so I think I think maybe the
good guys are dressed those [ __ ]
cosplayers or cosplay thieves who are
doing the right thing for the wrong
reasons against the wrong person for the
right reasons I like it mine from mark
genre body horror title tusks to another
podcaster goes looking through set of
circumstances winds up in the same place
as a craggly deformed looking old man
with weird scars all over and weird he's
also missing limbs and [ __ ] like that
and it's Justin Long's character who is
now the old man who's bendy walrus and
[ __ ] like that but it's still in his
head a walrus at heart
and there's a new victim who he's got to
pass it on to and [ __ ] can I make a tiny
tweak go go ahead what if Justin Long's
mania is not for walruses but for
mammoths for mammoths like woolly
mammoths something else with tusks baby
like just also test - so it's not walrus
it's something else with you something
else with tusks
so by that like it could be so it
couldn't be alright that's number one
it's clever tusks - M&E and ivory yeah
that was good were you building to that
you're a [ __ ] writer that was clever
I was sitting here trying to go like I'm
gonna bust a narwhal joke I was way
[ __ ] better man yeah there is that's
mine man and that's his what a great
question pick one of these you want
welcome to America how was your time in
the States been you've only been here
four days so far did they warn you
before he came over there like that's a
hostile country right now
no I've been loving it so far I love the
heat I come from Scotland even Scotland
soon it's great there's a lot of heat
going on Congrats
yes all right what do we got man we got
one bag left
does anybody the next person have an
accident cuz that was [ __ ] awesome
hey Joel Elston Joel I won't give it up
for Joel Joel what do you got for us man
JC likes your questions so let's hear it
thank you thank you um so I've been
rewatching the Batman 66 TV series
recently right on kind of playing around
in my head I started recasting so my
question for the two of you let's say
you are now in charge of putting out a
brand new version of the 66 trying to
keep it as campy as real to the original
series who are you casting in these
roles like I've already for instance I
thought
maybe kelsey grammer is king tut or
patton oswalt as egghead so who do you
have as maybe you're Batman you're Robin
you're Gordon somewhere in there I want
to live in your world man that's that's
good thing in number one that's gonna
win give it up for him ladies John
that's great question I will say this
when we were working on the clerks
cartoon years ago I worked with a very
talented fellow named of Dave Mandel and
stuff he came from Seinfeld and SNL
after us he went on to Curb Your
Enthusiasm and then he just did the last
two three seasons of veep now as big fat
deal with HBO and stuff Dave is like a
very funny idea person and and I love
him dearly he had an idea when we were
working on clerks on the cartoon he goes
if this works he's gone we should do my
dream show and I was like what's your
dream show and he goes cat man and I was
like what is it and he goes it's
literally just Batman again but we call
him Cat Man and he's like just like
fuggin we get an Adam West type and a
Bert war he's like I just want to make
that [ __ ] show so we'll just call cat
man and just like see if anyone notices
and [ __ ] I hope with this big fat HBO
deal that's what it you know ladies and
gentlemen cat man yeah like people when
they close their loops let's see my
Batman 66 now my can't be Batman now and
who would I cast god bless you
who's your Bruce Wayne well I was gonna
say you know putty but he already did it
in the tick right David Warburton yeah
hey pizza pillow head that dude is the
all-purpose gist Nathan field it's
you're perfect for it and every time you
need a Batman he's waiting let's see who
would I I would personally because I
think he's his [ __ ] hysterical I will
and he has played Batman I would go with
diedrich bader as Bruce Wayne Batman
so that would be my live-action Batman
66 equivalent who would be my Burt Ward
who could be Robin michael cera who's
played Robin once I think would make a
very earnest Boy Wonder because Michael
Cera is like 30-something by now
like he's no longer a boy but neither
was Burt Ward when he played Robin
so okay michael cera it's an awfully you
know now I'm getting hit up on Twitter
Batman so white so I got a [ __ ] mix
it up a little bit my Catwoman Leslie
Jones she just left SNL so she's free
and she funny my I mean [ __ ] kelsey
Grammer's King Tut as a genius idea like
[ __ ] I can't top that that's beautiful
when we see
I know I mean I'm sorry I'm having a lot
of fun in my head and I should really
just spit it out because I was sitting
there going who would Jeffrey Ross play
the Riddler like [ __ ] like that hmm
Joker I got a cast a joker hold on give
me a sec no suggestions because this is
important it's this is real work yeah
everybody shut the [ __ ] up this is
important it's modern-day Joker but it's
a Caesar Ameritech and so it's not gonna
be sinister Joker it's gonna be [ __ ]
happy-go-lucky Clown Prince of Crime
joke yeah boner Joker what is it boner
Joker doing committing boners Oh
boner Joker has a whole different
meaning to me I was like I want to see
that one man boner Joker what did he do
though like you know let's see who would
be the modern-day [ __ ] Joker who's
fun and sorry you got one but I have a
gun yet so i'ma save it up okay I think
he got him nailed the Joker I feel
pretty good about my Batman and Robin I
feel good about my Catwoman but like
Joker is important Joker's gonna come up
so many episodes if you're following
that model of Batman 66 when they grab
Cesar Romero he was like famous like 15
years prior to that [ __ ]
in movies and whatnot so I got to grab
somebody it was a right in this [ __ ]
down yeah - mom sorry my bad I'm really
taking it seriously you can tell like
when I'm the captured when the
imagination my question when the
question captures my imagination I get
really leg into it where I'm like no no
I can't just say some [ __ ] this
matters
it might be a little controversial I
might go with Michael J Fox as my Joker
very interesting all right facial hair
underneath the makeup oh my god
yeah you have to rock a mustache in
order to honor cesar romero a different
take I don't know like Michael J Fox we
all love them like I think we'd like to
see him play Joker my lone event if in
this fictional version the show I'm not
saying like it needs to happen but I'm
like I could I'd tune the [ __ ] in and
watch that be like what Marty McFly is
playing the [ __ ] joke boy this was
fun for me I'm gonna stop though you go
all right from my Bruce Wayne yes
Timothy Timothy Olyphant all the
fantastic is your Bruce Wayne yeah
because I think I think you don't want a
comic a comic actor for that like Adam
West was not a comedian like he was deep
thought he was playing [ __ ]
Shakespeare and he took it as seriously
as a heart attack fair fair so like I
think you want a person and I think like
all offense got a good sense of humor
and I think he can roll with it but like
he's a legit [ __ ] actor Donald Glover
is my Robin
nice hat woman [ __ ] a handsome bunny but
you took all day and I forgot it
[ __ ] blame your performance on mine
yeah Kristen Schaal he's my god woman as
I will time can I can I amend my Joker
yes Tracy Morgan
I'm gonna get you pregnant Batman every
episode my Riddler is Eddie Murphy oh
you got a lot of money for your show
Disney watch shows and for the Joker
okay also hold on hold that thought cuz
it's gonna be good but when you said any
Murphy did you see he is gonna [ __ ]
host Sarah alive yeah that was like the
greatest news I saw a holy place oh my
god these are the people Eddie and
December that's a save the date I can't
wait all right so back to your
jokey-joke my Joker is parker posey Wow
interesting
you have my gosh does she have a
mustache yes Parker will be wearing the
Cesar Romero Musto with makeup on we
gotta layer this two or three things
going on oh my god that was [ __ ] good
give it up for him that was a great
question you wanna take your damn bag
thank you Joe great [ __ ] job don't
forget your booty back that's the
important part man oh there it is we're
out of booty bags and everything's been
signed and we have no more [ __ ] news
that means the show is at an end ladies
and gentlemen do you have a good time
this evening
[Applause]
me too when do we do this again we do
this again in two Tuesday's on the 17th
so not next Tuesday but the Tuesday when
we have a guest for that Tuesday who are
we telling them we're no yeah and it's
it might be the shiniest guests we've
ever had in here like yes they meaning
they've won awards
they've won Oscars they have more than
one Oscar on their shelves have we ever
had an Oscar winner ownership I don't
believe we have who our first our first
alright wait who is it and it will be a
homecoming of sorts because here in the
cantina he was the guy who created many
of the creatures in the original canteen
Rick Baker's gonna be a big that's gonna
be on our [ __ ] man he's got a he's got a
autobiography that he's sort of going
around in and promoting and it was like
well can I come and be on your show and
I said yes he does every year he does
like these family photos with his whole
family like where he goes makeup crazy
and does what he does for you know won
Oscars for and they all look art
directed within an inch of their lives
it's really [ __ ] beautiful I don't
know what I would want to talk to him
about the most probably [ __ ] American
Werewolf and [ __ ] American werewolf's
effects still hold up to this day yeah
in a world of CG and [ __ ] like that like
I just watched that x-men movie and
every time beast went feral it was like
oh it's an effect and [ __ ] but the the
the watching his [ __ ] snout grow and
watching him look at his hand as it
stretched and [ __ ] and they did all that
with practical effects that [ __ ] still
[ __ ] works to this day and you're
also talking about the guy that invented
the Nazi werewolf's in that movie the
ones that come in
[ __ ] oh my god I can't [ __ ] wait to
talk to him alright sets in two weeks
that's in two weeks it also be our
second anniversary of doing a podcast
here the cantina is that right two years
being here that scum and villainy begun
asking when it comes to the bailiffs
[ __ ] a man well done that's you give
it up for mark he got a guest on Friday
if anyone's if people looking for [ __ ]
to do it eight o'clock Hollywood
babble-on me and Ralph going on right
down the street at the improv on Melrose
and whatnot the Hollywood improv tickets
at sea smog calm failing that we'll see
you guys in [ __ ] two weeks there's no
show
as you've seen without the guys standing
next to me give it up for mr. mark
Bernard enraged boy and that is Batman
Beyond for this week I'm Kevin Smith I
am rock renard tune in next time same
bat time same bat Channel smart guess
calm or youtube.com slash Kevin Smith or
the good of all Krieger night everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
you